that i'm convinced puts some kind of a
psychological pressure on us
and it can feel lonely at times hi there
steve coffin here today i'm going to
talk about a subject that doesn't come
up very often
it's loneliness loneliness and language
learning
remember if you uh like these videos
please subscribe click on the bell for
notifications
if you follow me on apple podcast or
spotify or
other podcast services i'd appreciate it
if you could leave a review
so
first of all i have received some
comments to the effect that my sound is
too low so i've worked on the
orientation of my microphone here and
hopefully this is better
uh loneliness so
it's a subject that never comes up we
think of language learning we're
learning to communicate with people
we're going to make new friends we're
going to connect with new cultures
so it's it's it's wonderful
and and of course language
is is not only a means of communicating
meaning
language is a means of connecting with
people i've even seen a theory that the
first humanoids develop language as a
means of sort of social grooming
it almost doesn't matter what we're
saying we just want to hear other
people's voices we say something so they
can hear our voices and we're just
connecting and that
serves a need a social need that we have
to connect with other people
now
when we're learning languages
of course we can be
in a classroom with other people where
we are connecting socially
but at some point to learn the language
we have to connect with the language we
have to listen and read as i always say
even if we're listening to someone or
speaking with someone
we're having trouble
getting the meaning because we're
working in a new language a language
that we're trying to learn
and i have had the experience
particularly when i
learned a language very intensively like
i did with chinese where i was like
seven hours a day in this chinese world
not just casually connecting with people
not watching movies that i
understood easily in my own language not
being with friends and family but
sitting there trying to
get my brain cells to get used to this
new language
and
sometimes and i can remember in hong
kong that when i would come out from
that and i would just communicate with
people
sometimes i felt a certain awkwardness
that the uh
this sort of intensive
interaction with a strange language
forcing the brain to get used to new
language patterns
can
you know create a sense of loneliness
you are alone with something that you
don't understand very well and like even
now for example you know my wife might
be watching
a movie on netflix in english or french
language where which we understand and
where in any case there are subtitles
for the french and it would be nice to
just sit there and enjoy the movie but
i at some level i want to work on my
arabic or my persian and so i go
downstairs by myself
and i work on these
uh whatever they might be
podcasts or
other you know lessons in our link
library where i'm
saving words and phrases and gradually
trying to get used to the language i
wander around the house with my airport
airpods in my ears
so that i can take advantage of whatever
time i have that i'm cleaning up or
something to get more of the language in
me i want to sort of force a change of
transformation of my brain so that i can
easily deal with this language
that i'm convinced put some kind of a
psychological pressure on us
and it can feel lonely at times
and so there are these ways in which
sort of intensive language learning
affects us
now that's no different than any other
pursuit that we go at sort of
intensively and there was a movie called
the loneliness of the long distance
runner i don't know much about the movie
i gather it had to do with social
classes in england
but anything you do you know with
intensity whether it be as a piano
player or as uh
you know a performance athlete or
whether you're pursuing you know science
or
whether it's
you as an individual
sort of striving to acquire knowledge or
skills in a particular field and you're
shutting yourself off from other people
that
can create a sense of loneliness now
there are many ways that we can you know
interact with other people whether we're
in science class or whether we have
teammates
or
language class or the people i talk to
online and i cherish the online
sessions that i have i was with
adele sammy of egypt this morning and
he's taking me through egyptian arabic
and those are wonderful moments and
those are social moments but there's
also a lot of time when it's it's lonely
it's just the learner and the language
and i just want to mention that because
it's something people should be aware of
they shouldn't consider it strange that
at times they feel lonely in their
pursuit of the language and it's
important to remember that ultimately
the reward is great
so i now communicate comfortably in
chinese japanese french russian
languages that i learned a while ago
and i
even finding now that i'm able to
communicate fairly comfortably in
persian with with sacra
persian being easier than arabic
now i've completely confused myself in
arabic because i've started into
egyptian arabic which is fun because
it's a it's a country where they speak
the language egypt is whereas there is
no country that speaks standard arabic
but it has kind of caused both of them
to get further confused
and so i've got to struggle with that
and i'm struggling with it you know on
my own so there is a certain loneliness
attached to language learning
until we get to a stage where we are
comfortable communicating and we kind of
rejoin the world around us so just a
thought that i had that i wanted to
share with you
bye for now